comedy network
this is not a great start this is a
bilingual american history podcast where
each week i
dave anthony read a story in spanish to
gareth
reynolds who listens in english that's
right i translate the words in my head
and this is gareth reynolds who has no
idea what this topic will be about
i don't either we got there that's gonna
be a problem what
we're breaking form this week dave
hasn't read it either
yeah so neither i don't have a story all
right
so let's start with the ads and then
let's
we'll get into it and i i have a plan on
how to get us out of this
we'll just alternate every other word
like um what's it called like a fire
drill what does that call when people
tell a story to each other
no that i'm not okay what
it's called oh i remember what it's
called hot shoelace
you're listening to hot shoelace oh my
god this is not okay
oh i shoot at the music jesus god well
now the phone went away
oh my the phone didn't go away what an
old person thing to say
oh the phone went away again he's
playing he's not playing
what the [ __ ]
would you like it louder it's what we
call a hot shoelace
all right well i hope you enjoyed that
how are your how are your ears
it's not it's not been a good episode so
far
you have a culvert this guy is coveted
over here just love the way that the
world works they just slip people
yeah it's like a name drop people
disease drop now
yeah no that's cool yeah i was uh
sniffling because i had a cold but uh do
you understand uh what i was saying
about traffic
ah i'm done i'm not done i can't handle
colds
i look dead boy he deserves to be
branded with an eye
yeah yeah we'll do that thank you um
so listen uh what huh
we are brought to you in part by
freshly right so you know a guy like me
i don't like to
i like to have an easy meal situation i
don't like to have a lot of stuff
i got to put together and just you don't
need to say any more
other than when you simply put it
together yeah yeah
your unique nickname is daddy
considering how you feel about your
father you're not calling me daddy
sup uh look so freshly
offers uh chef-made nutrient-packed
delicious
meals you can put in your face and and
eat them they come they come fresh to
your door
no cooking like i said that's the whole
jam no cooking um
so you don't have to grocery shop and do
that stuff where you get the different
pieces put together and apply settle
down settle it down
uh yeah your meals come they they're
cooked they're fresh every week
you can just keep the fridge stocked
they don't don't go in the freezer
and uh and you don't have to go to the
store right ordering's very easy you
just go to freshly.com
they got over 30 delicious uh really
good meals
steak peppercorn which i know you're a
big fan of steak sausage
they sent this chicken pesto ball ahead
they sent me some vegetarian ones
put your finger down great really great
yeah that's what i thought
uh so look it can fit your lifestyle you
know everyone's got different stuff
dietary needs preferences
tastes family sizes all that so right
now
our listeners can get actually for just
six dollars and sixteen cents
a meal so get on it uh your meals are
always delivered fresh they're not
frozen like i said
and they're ready to heat and enjoy in
just three minutes boom
so right now freshly is offering our
listeners 40 off your first two orders
when you go to freshly.com
stop stressing about dinner go to
freshly.com for 40
off your first two orders that's
freshly.com
for 40 off your first two orders
yes uh now we are also brought to you in
part
by gareth's favorite uh
my baby how do you know i know because
it's my jam it's what
it's jose and i it's our thing it's our
ad it's my ad we're brought to you by
paint your life oh paint your life and
i and jose we are one i mean so look so
if you're a guy and you have a cat
or other you like other people mostly
for a guy and his cat i guess
uh you go to paintyourlife.com right
yeah and then there it is it's basically
they take you give them a picture and
they
and they paint it you get a you get a
professional more than that
okay well go ahead it's so much more
than that it's it's a way to preserve
all right think about how saturated we
are with photos
there's no meaning anymore to photos you
take a photo of everything
so if you can take one of your favorite
photos and make it a painting
it elevates its importance and i didn't
think i was going to have a
life-changing moment when i got one of
my son jose
but it changed me you can see the paint
strokes comes framed
you go back and forth with them making
sure that like it's all good
shows up and then you just have a
painting of your cat on a bench
it just works people it works all right
so it's a quick and easy process you get
a hand painted portrait in about three
weeks
it makes the perfect birthday
anniversary wedding gift it's very
meaningful as you can hear it's very
personal
uh it can be trashed forever yes
basically it's my background when i
record things now
that's right so at your paint life.com
there's no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is
refunded guaranteed and right now is a
limited time offer get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and
free shipping to get this special offer
text the word dog to 64-000 that's
dollop264-000 text dollop
to 64-000 paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most did i mention
text dollop to 64-000
that's right that's right and we're also
brought to you
in part by squarespace squarespace of
course
a website domain
analytical tools online store marketing
tools they got it all it's
i've been working with squarespace
forever over a decade now
and uh we have our websites with them we
got the dollop website we got the dog
sources website we're in my website your
website all the websites
i i uh first
started working with squarespace because
they have super clean templates it is
super easy to use you don't have to like
update some
website you know garbage it's
it's all there for you and they have
everything you want if you want to sell
stuff
you want to do subscriptions you want to
do extensions
and you know all the information you
want all the analytics um they got 24 7
customer support they're there for you
and it looks good i mean that's the most
important thing i think with the website
it looks good it works good
uh so look uh check out squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use offer code
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or
domain that's right and uh we're also
brought to you
in part by a ritual a lot of people
taking vitamins it's the thing that's
happening out there
most people don't know what's in their
vitamin that's true and you should know
because there's there could be like
little pieces of cat or
if they're i'm not i'm not opposed to
that vitamin but i get the point
dirt it could be anything in there piece
of tire so look ritual
is like what if everybody knows what's
in their vitamin they got a clean vegan
friendly multivitamin it's formulated
with high quality nutrients in
bioavailable forms that your body can
actually use
yes as opposed to whatever you're doing
i know you do this
yes so relax i take ritual garrisons
ritual i like the
the taste thank you the taste garrus but
that's good whatever
garris takes um his i take mine i like
the taste
i do too it leaves it's like a it goes
down gives you a
mint kick that's right um
and i feel good i like to run around yep
it's part of my activity okay
like i said they're traceable uh so you
always know what nutrients you're taking
and where they come from
thanks to the one one of a kind visible
supply chain
and ritual is designed with your life
savings in mind women
men teens they're scientifically
developed to support different life
stages so check it out
get cree get key nutrients without bs
rituals offering our listeners 10 off
during your first three months visit
ritual.com to start your ritual today
hey uh aaron where did you go
oh so it's so so you're in you're in the
throes of this this guy's really going
to kill us
it's right sort
that is the right thing okay so we are
going on tour
we've just announced some u.s dates uh
right now
tickets are on sale for vegas salt lake
city denver san francisco
sacramento san diego we're still waiting
on the phoenix link i don't know what's
going on there
um but go to our adultpodcast.com
tour page and there you'll find
everything we're also going to be on
tour in australia perth adelaide
canberra sydney brisbane uh melbourne
auckland wellington
that's also that's new zealand yes that
is i've just discovered that
um yeah so join us for all those shows
we'll be back i also dave will be doing
some stand-up comedy
uh next weekend i will be in madison
wisconsin july
22nd through the 25th at comedy on state
august 5th i'll be at cb live in phoenix
arizona august 6th
uh or sorry august 6 through the 8th
i'll be at the
improv rally north carolina august 19th
hyenas in dallas
august 20th the state theater in austin
texas august 21st
the rec room in houston texas august
26th spokane comedy club
in spokane washington and august 27th
tacoma comedy club go to gareth
garethreynolds.com
for ticket links and other information
and
i was uh using the camera yeah i noticed
so it's a podcast most people listen
1580. whoa whoa all righty
year of our lord jesus christo
uh syphilis became the word wow hello
good morning coming in hot
hi hot syphilis became the worst
epidemic in europe since the black death
like that black death yeah black dead i
mean honestly they were like look the
last name was kind of a downer
yeah so we're just going to go with
something a little more rhythmic the
thing about the black death is
i mean maybe you could get it [ __ ]
but at least syphilis you're like yeah i
had i had one
good syphilis was 100 [ __ ] yeah
sylves is [ __ ]
you don't get slippery i guess you can
get it maybe from a
blowy i think they call it a medical
term blowy
medically speaking you had a blow job
maybe you could get it
maybe there's other ways to get it and
now i think it has to be an exchange of
fluids i think you gotta get yeah but
could i go buy a fella's fluids and
drink them
wait what's happening let's say i was to
go down to the
you know go see the you go to monger
you know and go down to his little shop
and yeah um well there were a lot of
come mongers back
then boy we're a [ __ ] family
yeah okay you know what let's go from
the top
and back all right go ahead we're dark
early go baby
um so in london the hospitals are just
packed with just syphilitic patients
obviously there's no antibiotics so it
just runs rampant through your body
really no matter what you try and you
sort of mr potato head basically right
like
well the pieces start falling off but
it's worse there's a nose and air
yeah but that's like part of it yeah no
that's part of it pieces fall off
um so they have open sores they have
terrible rashes
you go blind you can get dementia sure
and you go bald
in like a patchy bald world it's very
potato heady
it's sexy yeah so baldness it sucks that
when you're at your hottest you can't
screw right
next thing so baldness sweeps across
europe because of syphilis
okay um and a lack of hair isn't just
a bummer it's also an indication that
you could have std so if you're just a
bald dude people like
wouldn't bang him sheila wouldn't bang
that one
be very careful with that one oh i'd
have him
no i wouldn't if i were you he's got no
air on his head that's how i like him i
like him with no hair
no eyes you're about to go through a bit
of a dry spell i think
shouldn't be doing that uh so long hair
became a thing
like long hair was in it was like you're
healthy
you know um sure baldness really damages
your rep
okay okay samuel uh
pepis wrote quote if my brother lives he
will not be able to show his head
which will be a very great shame to me
wow so your bald brother you feel great
shame
due to him yeah so syphilis leads to
wig-making it's just it's early and
very bizarre
okay but that makes sense so yeah okay
so
because you want to shag you know you
put a little thing on yeah people want
to hide their
their science shiny syphilitic you know
dome up there but even if you're not
cephalitic you're just
yeah it's a lot harder yeah um the wigs
could also be used
to hide sores on the face so some
syphilis
people are going undercover as rags and
then some regs are just like why the
[ __ ] can't i have sex
and i i hate to say this so we've got
what we call saw wings
this is a new thing i've got and it's
called the saw wig and what it basically
is is you put a wig
upon your saw yes you make it look more
like
say a bit of a mullet or a bit of a shag
look something like that and if anyone
asks what the problem is you just say no
i just grow a bunch of different fancy
hairstyles this one's a beehive
and then you've got your regular wig too
so to be like nine different wigs
essentially you've got your head wig
by the way that could be a show nip put
a pin in that and then you've also got
your saw wigs
you know your wigs for your saws to
cover them up so there's someone says
sorry mate is that a bit of a saw there
you can go sore i don't know what you're
talking about this is just a little
hairstyle growing out of my chin
that's high what's a show no
no no you said put a pin in that
oh well i just have always been thinking
of this one idea for a
musical but but no no no no
i should not leave the path of the
family business
we make saw wigs although when i'm alone
at night i often
think about how great a musical could be
just
hedwig it's always just come to me i
just see this
image this blonde hair this
larger than life character but every
time i'm writing one of my songs my
father comes in and burns it
anyway um are you interested in any of
the swords i'm sorry i came in here
yes of course you are it's got a bit
weird didn't it yes
i just wanted a spot of tea oh i'm sorry
there's tea shops next door we're soar
wigs
oh yes sorry about that okay but would
you like a musical
no you didn't like this okay i
understand i understand you sorry as you
were
um so
this meant that wigs aren't a style
they're there to hide you know your
your shame right sure they're also
called periwigs i'm not going to call
them periwigs but that's what they call
them periwigs okay um so in france
the only people who wore um
wigs were people who were balding
fancy sex workers like elite you know
sure and then
obviously people with red hair
because we're talking about shame
you know it really feels like the arrow
turned upon the
shooter didn't it but then that changed
in 1655
when uh louis the 14th started going
bald
uh the sun king yes he's 17
wow and he's probably has syphilis
that's why he's oh okay well he probably
because he ends up dying a syphilis he's
just like at the end he's just like a
like just a body ravaged by civilis well
i mean
and for those of you picturing at home
it would be king potato head
that's right with holes in it yes well
that's the potato head
so he is 17 he's been he's
he he like became king when he was
foursomes he's been king for a while and
by the way that if anyone ever wants to
make a case against the monarchy
right there boom it makes sense it may
make a total sense who's not gonna
listen to a four-year-old that's
i mean that's your boss goddammit this
is actually what we always have running
america anyway
that might be it would be a little
freeing it would be more understandable
we'd be like
he's four i understand so
louie hires 48 wig makers to make a
ton of wigs for them why not get some
doctors there too wouldn't the doctor or
two couldn't hurt the problem right
spend the whole budget on the wig makers
while you go you're still dying of
syphilis
it's not you know you look so hot
[Laughter]
could you imagine would that not be is
there a larger football
me i've got so much hair downloaded to
my nose
[ __ ] my nose it's i'm oh no it's fine
here okay ah you said the [ __ ] are your
nose
my tongue fell out
that's hot hey look at how cool her hair
is
hey look how sweet the hell do you like
her stairs no
hit oh yeah my trout my shot is dropped
like a transmission
it's not
so because the the president because the
um
king is wearing wigs and they take off
first they start you know the
the people in the courts yes people in
the court start wearing them
um and then and then you know just
trickles down then everyone starts
wearing wigs
um in paris the number of wig makers
went from 21673 to 835 in 1768. so
okay i mean that's a big sure now hair
hairs
and we don't need to get the word out
about the syphilis just let's wig it up
that's right
and hair is harvested from the heads of
rural working-class people as a child as
it should be as it should be
it should be you should go let them live
with the shame of baldness
yeah yes uh i'll have his hair and a bit
of his thank you
and then you give him just like a penny
or something good luck with everything
there you go [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off sorry that hurt so much uh so
king charles
ii of england also gets into the french
wig fashion
he did it to cover his prematurely grand
hair also
probably from syphilis okay oh yeah
great wow yeah you go gray from
your syphilis is just is [ __ ] it's
like uh it's like
it's covety it's cool that's awesome no
that's great though you see you got that
raiden hair that's
awesome um so
he then brings the trend to england
uh and they're same thing the the nobles
the
people in the court they start wearing
them then the merchant class starts
wearing them
they cost about a week's worth of wages
for
a just a normal dude in london so that's
a week's worth would be a week's wages
a week's well that's why they called it
a win
and so most people can't afford that
obviously
but british nobility would spend over
like 800 shillings
on just crazy wigs and that led to the
term
bigwigs that's where the term big weeks
come from hot shot royal family
shot big wig that now in 800 shillings
then is about 10 000 today so these
people are spending 10 grand on a wig
wow so wig guilds wow
gotta unionize wow
[Laughter]
so which guilds forbid anything but
human hair wigs
for b okay so they're very they're right
so they're basically like we will take
them off of other citizens yeah
and other people are like would you like
this one made from
dog that's right well not everyone could
afford that so they also would
people would make them from horse or
goat hair for
or they'd slip it in sweet goat hair
imagine a horse like if you didn't go to
the main like
yeah yeah right but i feel like i've
seen like wigs or like
things made from horse hair oh really
yeah i feel like i've seen that over the
years
goat hair i don't think i because when
you like it's not that bad good starts
go tears in the bed if you're seeing go
with long hair it's not that bad i guess
i'm picturing these kind of little i
mean i only hang out with shitty goats
yeah yeah i mean shady guys i hang out
with like an alley
sure i'm i'm more like oh you're
hobnobbing with
yeah elite goats yeah most of the goats
i hang out have syphilis
okay how'd they get it
okay so um
at this time people didn't bathe this is
pre-bathing so
cities are filthy people are filthy now
people think that if they
that they can get good stuff here i'm so
down on society now
like this is so refreshing to hear that
everyone's walking around in horse wigs
cyphlytic the pieces are dropping off
and they don't bathe
that's right there would probably be no
better time to be bathing than right now
it seems
so people thought they could get sick
from bad smells we've talked about that
before
yeah and the wig would trap all kinds of
odors sure so you walk around the city
there's the smell and it's just going
into your wig
it's like when you go to a club and
they're smoking and you have a jacket on
and then your jacket smells except it's
different it's the smell of the death
and city
so people start scenting their wigs this
is [ __ ]
nuts what the hell
god violet rose jasmine orange lavender
just
pumping it in there um nobody
thought to wash it no one was like we
should wash this yeah i was that's the
first thing i was
like yeah you can't because it's hair
you could easily wash it yeah yeah
take care of you nobody thought of that
no so people are just lavendering up
these bo
by the way that smell that bo scented
smell like yeah
you know he threw some rose water on a
[ __ ] bee oh it's like guess what
still smells horrible oh it's the worst
uh people did rub their hair with a
napkin to quote dry it from its
sweatiness and filth and they're just
they're just in private just sort of
dabbing around
with a napkin while they're just sitting
there with their weird patches and
sores open sores ugh
it's nice so perry wigs took on their
own sort of social
thing specific styles were appropriate
for some professions but not others
right so it
kind of becomes a thing and and the same
way you have like a hairstyle
association with your occupation
and the same went for people's place in
society right so what is it like
the fancy long ones were for the tip top
guys and then what are the shorter
shoes you'd have like a shorter normal
looking one and that would be more you
know you're
lower right your merchant or whatever
sure you're okay so there's a wig
echelon
a goat would be like the guy cleaning
out trash
got any more rubbish whoo don't mind if
i do
where are we all clubbing legs are there
yeah there's no we're not you know so
i'd love to hang out a bit no it's no if
you smear
uh that smell of milk and [ __ ] that's my
wig but
you'll get better as the day goes on no
it won't uh
just you can't wash hair you know why
are you talking to me
i'd like to be friends you've got a
lovely wig and i really
would love to be hanging out with people
in a weak circle of this nation
oh no absolutely i'd love to be your
friend maybe
a wrong let do you mind if i'm dabbing
inside of my wig for a minute while
we're having discipline
well hold on let me just take it off
[ __ ] me don't worry it's bitter brain
bitter brain never hurt anybody did it
there we are it has and it
does can't remember which way i'm
supposed to put this on properly see
like that does that look right hello
yes so what we're doing later than
dinner
yeah i've got a syphilis really oh
i know yeah i'm dying a lot
but you can't tell can you i can't
yeah you barely know she's actually no
it's very obvious guess who's got
syphilis you yeah you wouldn't know
about looking at me would you no very
much so
i've gotta have another dab inside a
sweatshirt bloody match
oh oh christ the worms in my head
all right got to go i'm gonna remember
your home
come back oh no yeah
oh no syphilis knows where i live yeah
that's
my name um
so you know the fancy ones
they became like the the rich people the
fashionable
ones become bigger and more decorative
right it's kind of like what happened to
hats
yes but with wigs curls and bows and
they're harder to keep up introducing
the
wig wig a wig for your wig also
um a very nice place for insects oh god
so it is like
buggy people who wore wigs had a lot of
lice
oh my god so you're like if you have
syphilis
yeah go ahead your life is just a
walking nightmare it's not great
your skin already hurts your hair is
falling out you have sores and then
there's
bugs involved but i also feel like by
the way what a great situation
for a bug it's just like hey cool look
at that living tissue
right in here i also feel like everybody
probably had lice
like i know that i mean it just i would
think that everybody would have lice and
everything like how would you get rid of
it if you're not bathing like you shave
your head but then the status yeah you
can shave your they were and there were
nice combs but whatever
nice combs historian and they still have
those
do they yeah do they work yeah well they
it won't matter
in conjunction with other troops you
know you can't get rid of lights have
become immune to the stuff you used to
put on
to kill them so now you have to go
there's lice
it's called hair fairies there's a
franchise where you go if you have kids
that get lice
and they comb and i've had i know a
couple people this happened to and they
and they had to take them out by hand
i would just go to a capuchin why not
suicide okey dokey that got dark
um yeah i know someone that they have
two kids and twice they got lice and
they had to go to that place twice and
once one person in the house gets it
everyone in the house gets it that's
what's cool about it
yeah everyone gets a rip
anyway that's modern day yeah let's get
back to the gross time
uh quote this is a historian andrew
duncan quote
the existence of lice was rife within a
where's wig
coating the hair in such disgusting
numbers
it was recommended people use combs to
get the lice out but the hairstyles of
wigs were so
fancy it made combing them impossible
on the other hand their actual hair was
so full of grease and dirt that it was
much easier to style a wig
so it's a real big trade-off going on it
wasn't a good time oh my god
pre-soap pre-regular baths
everything is and toothpaste everything
is horrendous
it's all around how would you i could
not imagine getting syphilis because
there's
no chance i'd want to bang can you you
would though because it would be
normal you'd be like ah that's just what
we do
oh my god the smell can you imagine this
no i can oh my god dave i bottled that
dave fashion was a big deal in king
charles card everyone wore boots and
fancy leather circle ribbons on the
toes just all kinds of sure giant hats
huge collars
cuffs slash sleeves and of course the
wigs
right and puritans hated this okay
you know they've been pretty consistent
and when puritans came to america they
brought that hatred to america
right cool but the massachusetts
colony as it became more established
and more non-puritan people started
arriving
like that that because culture became
well they're
like so the puritans first get there and
we're like we hate all the fancy dress
we hate it all and then other people
start rolling and going that's not that
bad
right so it's gonna like it and the
puritans came
you know they got upset by this these
new people and they wore
they wore things like wigs
i mean yeah puritans are always still
are so annoying
john elliott considered wigs to be an
attack
upon his religion oh can you him
ah a wig it means a slap in god's face
i guess that's what yeah as they grew in
popular god would have given you hair if
he wanted you to have it
he said quote the lust has become
insufferable
like you just can't get rid of it like
it's just right okay
right okay i think they said
insufferable it was inseparable
it's not insufferable insufferable which
means
you're not gonna be able to beat it it's
just okay insufferable is like
yeah it's also insufferable nah [ __ ] you
okay so he's mad about the screwing yeah
right
so wigs wigs are also
like a symbol of growing a consumer
society
right like blue jeans yeah i mean it's
kind of like blue jeans right
yeah it's as people move to the colony
it becomes it also becomes harder to
know where neighbors
and acquaintances and business partners
are from
because there's supposed to be a social
hierarchy
and now people are just dressing the way
they want
right so lines are blurry
you used to be able to basically know
someone's deal based on appearance no
before
before you knew someone's deal because
you had personal knowledge or your
family had personal knowledge of that
person but now
people are moving around the globe and a
lot of people are moving a lot of places
and so you're meeting new people right
and it's like the world was going to
college and so
but then then people are coming in and
and there was a way that you recognize
everybody how what their status was with
your clothes and possessions right but
if you're just
away you could you belong to a certain
group in the appropriate social circle
and all that
and then you it also meant the poor and
other unworthy people
you know right you look like that but
now with wigs
and fancy clothes you could come to
america and roll in and be like no i'm
rich
yeah i'm a rich guy with a wig right so
a lot of people still do that yeah i
mean and so this became a big concern
for the puritans like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
because now you don't know how loud yeah
right
so the puritans in new england wanted to
put an end to all that nonsense and in
the plymouth general court banned many
of the fancy
fashions okay but wigs were not
this is in america yeah okay so they've
come to this land for all their freedom
and right away they're like yeah
no they'll be a uniform that's right
yeah
and so they don't ban wigs but they hate
them like they're all
against them and then in 1649 the
general court of massachusetts passed an
order condemning the wearing of long
hair by men
because it was contrary to god's word
that's true
yeah you know god you think of jesus
think about how short that crop oh no
that he was like he had like a bunch
of buzz cut yeah like he was like jesus
yeah when i see jesus i'm like is he in
the marines like what's this guys
when i think of jesus i picture oliver
north picture of yep
total almond north ripped as [ __ ] yeah
red
cats bullet like nice bullets
yeah he's got a bandolier uzi knife in
his mouth yeah that's my jesus yeah
yeah so
how easy an argument to win though what
about jesus
that's i think that's the worst argument
to religion you're like but what about
jesus
yeah it kills everything that they know
the guy that's all
based around how he's giving and like
not judge remember that
yeah so right so long hair is out it's
contrary to god's words the court
entreated all elders of the jurisdiction
to manifest their zeal against it so
they're like
okay everybody sit in a circle and
really shoot mind lightning at their
hair
that's right yeah that's my lightning
get my lighting
or eye lasers either way lasers do it
no so they're saying get out there and
give everybody [ __ ] who's [ __ ]
wearing wigs
right come come down hard on these dudes
so it's
peer pressure to get out the wig right
[Music]
in 1654 thomas hall wrote a uh treatise
titled
the lonesomeness of long hair
yeah i mean you know you worry about
what happens when people don't have
anything to fixate on but
this is not one of those situations
he said it was again it was against the
civility of america
and it followed the spanish and french
quote who are yet known
pappas and idolaters so oh so he's just
i mean yeah i mean again it all kind of
forms from this biblical like
you know you've got to be true to it's
religious
it's yeah it's really and there are a
couple places while reading there are a
couple places in the bible where it says
men should have short hair it's actually
in there in a couple places but
who knows the way the bible usually
works there's another place where it's
like did you have long hair like it's
all
the things whole thing
here's your human uniform
the bible a fashion guide
uh harvard became a concern because many
of the students
were going to go on to be ministers and
they'd be setting moral standards for
the next generation
right so in 1655
harvard forbade students to quote wear
long hair
locks or four taupes i have no idea what
that is
that was a band the four times right the
four tops nor use curling crisping
parting
or powdering their hair so very so
really
i mean this hairstyle is whatever jesus
picked that
yeah they want everyone to look like
dancing this is a dancing everyday bed
head yeah
whatever you look like you look like for
the day
what about brushing your teeth isn't
that well there's no didn't god want
that yellowy film to form and that
stinky tongue to exist
the only thing you could do is rub
or no lick your palm with your eyes and
then rub it on your hair
saliva is the lord's palmate i've always
said god's witness
god will decide what ye look like if he
wants you to have stubble you'll have
stubble a beard a beard
let him form you we are all god's barbie
dolls
god likes a a very short uh trim with a
bit of crockett and tubs if you will
when it comes to pubes he loves a big
old bush oh god loves a big bush let it
roll
boys and girls and i like to put my face
in there and just
it's taking a turn biblically sorry i
said i
did not mean to say i it's still weird
either way
okay let's all hold hands well i think
we maybe need a better segue
let's touch each other's that one first
one works actually
special part nope
[Music]
i feel alone all right uh
so the people of roxbury roxbury is
right near
uh is that in boston roxbury uh yeah but
actually it's in massachusetts yeah okay
the people of roxbury petitioned the
court because
the harvard college students were
gallivanting around in their long hair
so
in 1972 it doesn't matter like they
passed this thing at harvard but still
the kids are like
i [ __ ] like my i like my wigs right
um okay
uh yeah who doesn't and uh they said all
the students quote
lust for long hair first took head and
break out at the college i don't know
what what head and break means but
what is it what they first took head and
break out at the college they first took
head and break out at the college that's
right
okay you got a problem with that i'm big
time i'd love to know what it means
um i think you give someone head and
then you go whoa oh wow
surf's up um and then they said from
there
their long haired [ __ ] was spreading
out to pulpits and causing grief
and and offense in the area what
what is the year when religion learns to
not put things in the spotlight
because it makes people want to do it
that's not gonna okay
puritans like samuel sewell a
judge and printer in the massachusetts
colony believed
the wearing of wigs to be a gauge of
moral character
sure he attended harvard he graduated in
and the whigs
he saw it as a repetition of the corrupt
world that puritans hated
right it's everything it's corruption
it's sure everything it's everything bad
right and when they're normal everything
seems fine and normal with this person
yes he's totally normal when wigs first
came to new england
they're not the flamboyant version
that's an elitist england at this point
they're more modest they're smaller but
still many puritans are upset by them
but years later right now we've they've
been in america for a while
and they're becoming more fancy is there
any association to syphilis anymore
is this now just purely i mean they're
magnetic there has to be but
it became a fact i know now i started
wearing it right but sure i think it
helps the flitic dudes right
and and they assume ladies like you you
you had it you could throw a wig on but
now everyone's doing it
yeah but i would think those things have
like a weird symbiotic relationship
right like
so many people are getting syphilis
still at this point yeah of course
everyone's yeah civilization's not
it's not hasn't gone anywhere i was
hoping it would gonorrhea
i wish there was a bell we could ring i
would love it
i've been requesting a bell aaron come
on
um so puritan said whigs were quote
many times used for disguise by the
worst of men
as shaven crowned popish priests
highway robbers etcetera popish pr
catholic priests right because they're
they're not they're
protestants yes but still i mean bury
this hatchet there's not
enough arguments about the invisible
human in the sky it's not going on
come on um yeah okay so
so they're very it's a slippery slope
with the wigs soon
you know you're putting on one or two
just to have a little fun next thing you
know
you're catholic right that's how it
works and that's not good
uh now this this quote i just read is
shaven crown polish priests
um that was of course from the famous
puritan
nickel nicholas noyes essay titled
an essay against perry wiggs
nicholas noyes yeah he wrote uh i love
that comic yeah he wrote a he wrote
a really great essay against wigs sure
okay
cool well i just left some guys sitting
down and because i am
pissed off about wigs [ __ ] wigs
disgusting no
do you think the bad rat wore wigs
he also said quote the hair of women is
suitable
to their soft moist cold constitution
but not the masculine hot and dry
constitution of men ah so he's like the
ben shapiro of the 1600s
yeah that's right so to him women are
wetter and softer and so
and so hair works on them better women
are obviously soaking wet fish
and men are dry husks
i'm nikki noyes
this uh wig wearing
would create this is he he said the wig
wearing the
the man wearing the wig which shouldn't
be on him of course not because it
doesn't
jive yeah obviously he said it's dry
dave what's he gonna do with a wig
he said it would create an unnatural
inconsistency between the face
and the hair and that it was like the
monstrous
locus in revelation 9 7. wow i mean
and again i mean like you know i'm not
saying the other arguments i've heard
are cogent and good you know what i mean
but this one is particularly
like not anywhere close to good no this
is like a
i mean this would be a disappointment
this would be a flop this flops
yeah this is not great and also if
someone says this you're like
what about just like calming the [ __ ]
down like what about i can't calm the
[ __ ] down
think about it listen to me a dry man
wearing a wig his face
embryos are gonna bleed up into that and
then that will cause
him to have a moistening therefore
metamorphosis
is happening next thing you know your
friend
is no longer a man but he is a wet woman
okay so i just i'm we just we talked
about we think you should take a
like i'm not taking a break i think you
need i'm doing some of my best work
you've never seen nicki noise this hot
chick
yeah no we saw you this hot before it
was when there was the shoe
uh the shoe i'm sorry i just can't
believe men would wear laces what are
they foolish idiots that'll turn them
into trolls okay but we went
making noise on the ones and chicka
chickas we went through the shoe rage
yeah that was the rage is not done yet
it feels like i've seen some lace boys
out here today i'm not happy about
it unfortunately there's bigger fish to
fry and these ones are made from goat
hair
it feels like you're getting just as hot
as nicki noire's getting just as hot in
the
yeah i am that's right i'm hot and i'm
pissed
okay yeah you are supporting
a movement that is terrible i'm not they
are good
listen to me dumb [ __ ] they are going to
have
hair locusts am i the only one who is
reading revelations
is it nikki noah chuckapoka yeah no
we're all we're all reading them we
are yeah yeah yeah are you fathoming it
we can because i'd love for you to
fathom it
i don't see the connection between wigs
and locusts
and revelations they are gonna put um
i'll walk you through it
take my hand through the valley of
stupid where you live they are gonna put
on the wig
and then they're no longer going to be
dry guys they're going to be weddies
and then that's going to create a
condition where the locusts much like in
revelations come out and start eating on
them
if you want your friend you're going
gonna need him to
be like cool okay chicky won
nicki noise just go ahead and send him
in um
like sent yeah we'll just go ahead and
take him away now ah
okay take me away nothing just uh might
just hang out here for a sec
i would love to hang out here and uh
plenty of men to shout at
something there's one now some gentlemen
going to come in and help you great oh
hey what's up fellas it's me nikki what
chickenpop noise now
sewell helped to get the writings
of people like noyes out there because
he was a printer he soon became the
official printer of the colony so he
held sway but he was also like the my
pillow guy let's just say
he's also really against wigs
he's on harvard's board of overseers
he's on what a great
by the way harvard bravo again in the
name department
he's on the council of assistance which
is like uh
it's like judges and legislators
together sure um and he's also a judge
in his own he's very influential right
right he's he's a big
he's a big wig erin where's the bell
we requested it months ago the
uh so to the anti-wig puritans the fight
anti-wig there are times when we'll be
in the middle of these and i'm like just
think about what just got said it's been
normalized because you've led me here
but i mean the anti-wig puritan yeah
it's
it's so by the way think about how much
they eventually wear wigs
no i know so i mean they're not winning
this battle they're fighting so
to them it's mostly about age and gender
which they
thought had to remain very defined
couldn't be disrupted
or the entire physical social moral or
order of society would just be destroyed
they're like the wigsboro baptist church
that's right so wigs are serious
business to them like it's a real
[ __ ] concern sure dave dave i did not
mean it's a problem
i didn't mean to downplay it i think
it's serious well you did you did
downplay
i've had some fun but obviously i think
it's a serious thing well it's it's
no [ __ ] different than the communist
i agree
getting into [ __ ] vietnam and
domino's start goddamn
it's the same thing but it's wigs i
agree let's just go back in
okay the character of gareth is gonna
have fun but i agree this is serious
[ __ ] okay
thank you thank you so
richard godbeer what who
is the best named person ever
hello you know what you should make
what potato chips what's the deal
uh fruit i'm god beer
yeah drink ale upon me you i would never
stop walking around doing that hello god
beer getting some water
should be god beer so this is god beer's
quote
wig wares upset indispensable
hierarchies
and threatened to confound the
distinctions between men and women
without
which a virtuous and orderly society
could not survive
so that's really what they believed
right wig-rying was seen as a unique
threat
also god had made man with hair and
putting on a wig was to say
god's word was bad right right it's uh
yes we cannot note him
no we no you do not note god he is the
publisher and the author
that's correct but not all puritans are
on board
uh especially the first generation of
puritans who came from england were
super against wigs and fancy dressing
but then the second generation their
kids
right actually start to embrace these
you know degenerate
ways wigs and clothes cotton mather was
a puritan minister these names are
really getting spicy
cotton mather yeah hello i'm god beer
and i'm cotton mather
we're puritans he's a minister he's born
in the colony in 1663
so he's second generation his father was
a well-known minister named
increase mathers increased math they're
sorry
do we need do we want to take a break
his name was increase matter
increase mathers that's right more
mather more mother
and mormon give me more
no his name is increase matters uh-huh
that's right increase it
all right give me more all right take it
up a notch okay increase matter
one more mather give me another matter
increase that a little bit don't worry
give me more
it's shaking take it to 11. it's shaking
increase matter oh my god
so he is increased matters
really against wigs which he called
horrid bushes of vanity
how you know he was popular i increased
bathroom smith yeah
decreasing uh increased blamed the
recent
burning of like someone like heard
increase i was like that's actually a
pretty good first name
we need to increase the agriculture yeah
i'm gonna go for a walk for a minute
boys
i think i know what i'm gonna name baby
mather he's
increased do you think they named him
that because he was gonna grow and get
bigger
it will increase it can't go
and this is growing sharp
[Laughter]
uh so increase blame the recent burning
of boston on wig wearing so he's like
look we're wearing wigs that's why the
[ __ ] city burnt down
sure yeah absolutely um because lord
the lord kindles yes fires because of
wigs
wigs are kindle fire absolutely so
cotton was good friends with sewell even
though right they're on the opposite
side of the wig right uh battle
um they're boy he was born 10 years
after him so sue was first generation
okay cotton saying they they had they
hang on the same circles
they have many of the same friends they
eat together all the time
and they talk politics but the only
place they never agreed
wigs wigs it's broken up a lot of great
friendships
cotton wore a long brown curled prairie
wig that emphasized his big nose
that's so they also were a little show
that [ __ ] off teacher
yeah yeah i think that's right i want to
showcase the beak
oh i have a big nose i wonder what else
yeah i have it's
big hair big yeah
instead of a wig sewell wore
a skull cap to hide his bald dumb and
keep it warm
so sewell i mean but god didn't
like i know god didn't give you but they
but they're thinking like well it's
it's hair so you're you're you're you're
you're fat
you're fabricating reality whereas this
is just sort of
a bald hat
okay cotton went as far as to defend
wigs during a sermon oh my lord
when sewell hurt i would say i wouldn't
even say still heard about sewell
uh he would read he thought cotton was
an amazing minister so he would read his
sermons
right and um he liked them so much that
sometimes
he would bind them in leather and get
rid of their friends
okay you should read it but he believed
probably strongly in the separation of
church and wig
that's right and he's not going to like
it if you're throwing in a little bit of
your wig
stuff uh so when seoul
read it he said quote i expected not to
hear any vindication of pear wigs in
boston pulpit by mr mather oh
decrease matter but khan's definitely
not alone this
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
pro-wig guys and this means
anti-wig puritans would run into a lot
of resistance in the puritan community
when they
tried to rally people against the
dangers of wigs i mean how hard
i like if you're a puritan you agree on
so much [ __ ]
i mean this is basically like
republicans and democrats
you know what i mean it's just like look
just [ __ ] move on talk about
something different
figure out something else you all agree
on tons of crazy [ __ ]
like just you know this sticking point
it's a wash
so as far as the age argument
they said wigs destroyed the order of
things
covering gray hair or baldness could
create chaos totally in a society
because
they valued respecting the old and wise
sure well what a great indictment on
your feelings
on other generations of people you see
if we don't we'll accidentally respect
people
no they're saying they wouldn't respect
anybody no respect yeah no respect
yeah no so it's the land of rodney
dangerfield hey
i kill you there's nobody who's got a
wig on the works huh
okay there's nobody here to respect
everybody's so youthful looking
so all they just supposed to be revered
and they're supposed to instruct the
young
and counsel them but with wigs on they
became quote ridiculous and contemptible
yeah
that's right you don't know who to
respect anymore i mean could you imagine
if you dab put on a wig you'd be like
what the [ __ ] who is this guy
ah sir you you stay i don't know what to
do
you didn't even know who was old anymore
i mean
imagine it was just so crazy beverly
hills it's just like well yeah it's
still frank under the wig it's not like
there's a [ __ ] five hundred thousand
guys cruising around boston right yeah
right hardly
you know everybody knows each other
of course uh men wearing wigs was also
unmanly
this is the gender part right womanish
and effeminate
puritans worried that if a man became a
feminine in one respect that could
spread to others
right and then let's kick that can
further next
and you know i wonder if that's yeah uh
uh amazing that in 2020 uh 2021 we're
still having the same argument yes
truly yeah i mean it's it this is this
is trans people it's the same
but it's they literally had the same
[ __ ] argument about wigs
and they've lost so much now they're now
they're just down to that doing it yeah
they keep they can't [ __ ] stop doing
it like it will all
end yeah this thing happens and it
started with wigs and now we're down the
[ __ ] line never ends
so rev reverend wigglesworth what he
better be pro [ __ ] wing reverend
wigglesworth if he's anti-wing
then he should not believe in god the
lord started my last name with wig he
hath cursed me to a life of pro
he said long hair was a quote token of
women's subjection
while short hair was given to men as a
natural sign of his rule
and i want to be i no i want to go as
from now on is reverend's
worth i want to be known as
reverendsworth
i'm cutting the wig out or no it would
be lizworth
i'm going by reverend lisworth we were
thinking about calling you wigsworth
no [ __ ] off i mean no please don't
whoops yeah you really that was
um you're blasphemed we're purifying i'm
reverend as little worth you're an ass
clown
well reverend as clown it is i hate wigs
um noise said that if it was
if it was quote a shame of a man to wear
long hair of his own it was much more
shameful to wear long hair of
another's body and especially of women
and and i'd
maybe you mentioned this but as far as
growing your own hair out
also not okay that's also not okay but
literally not as bad as the wig
the wig [ __ ] is bad but really they want
you to have a nice a nice tight cut
sure right yes of course yeah uh also
women who provided
hair for men's wigs were guilty of
becoming more like men
right of course that's like your hair
connection yeah so they're
look sorry ladies the goal here is to
grow it forever i don't know what your
deal is
trimming are you going to a dude ranch
good lord
and women who had their heads shaved
completely
were no better than cheaper ghosts
popular [ __ ] has ever thought of that
like going after like things that are
you know what i mean being like we're
pro-swearing
like what you know what i mean like
embracing something instead of just
being like
we're the lifeguards you're friend
and women who had their head shaved
completely were no better than sheep or
goats
noise quote a woman degrades herself
unto the rank and quality of a beast
when she submits to be shorn as the
besar
you know what's amazing is the person
who thinks immediately to start
comparing a woman to an
animal it's probably not the person you
want
just speaking on behalf of women no also
it's uh
just to put this out there it's a
[ __ ] haircut well
um i don't know that's a little simple
another puritan went further and said
a goat's hair was taken involuntarily so
the goat was not as bad as the woman who
came in
[ __ ] ever eat meat have you ever
eaten meat prick have you ever eaten
meat you prick
have you oh well i've picked my blip
you know you're actually taking from the
lord if you think about it's like yeah
i'm sorry what are crops [ __ ]
are you supposed to just eat your
fingernails forever is that the goal
that's your meal
your life is drinking your own piss and
spit and living off your fingernails and
eyebrows
yeah there's some nutrients um that
woman
was quote more goat-ish or at least
foolish
than the goat like i would literally sit
there with a dumbfounded look on my face
for two seconds and just walk away
be like uh i mean i just got so much
dumber from this guy
that's why the lady is a goat
so in 1675 when war with native
americans broke out
puritans wondered what had brought god's
wrath upon them
and god's wrath here being the war
but the war that they're waging well
there it's a it's a two-way war
obviously
sure it's the white man's renaming tour
it's not a great
yeah it's not a when you go to war
you're not like what if
what if we're going who did this to us
we're going on a war to discover things
that have been found
so they decided that one of the causes
was clearly quote men wearing long hair
and periwinks i hope you're happy
well look what you've done longhand
another fine mess you've gotten us into
some pointed out that the long
hairstyles looked a lot like native
american hairstyles
i mean but what is the connection do you
see they both
well then wouldn't happen wouldn't that
be natural
if the native americans it wouldn't that
be a natural hairstyle yes
but what are they i mean like what what
is god what like
god gave scissors to people for cutting
but also two things your hair and your
bush but
also like i mean whatever i obviously
like at this time
the version of god is like still
probably pretty close to what he is now
in people's heads
where it's just like this you know white
man god yeah but at some point
you have to also approach the fact that
if god put hair on your head
and that like there's also other people
here yeah
and it just doesn't it doesn't work it
just doesn't it doesn't all jive like
the rule you keep inventing the rules
it's like when you would play like when
you were a kid and you'd play like
shooting the shooting game and someone
would be like i have a bulletproof face
you'd be like well now there's no get i
don't even know what the rules are
anymore there's no rules
but also like what you can wear clothes
but not yeah
i mean yeah right exactly see you can
wear you can't take a goat's hair
but you can eat a goat you understand
this is where we live
it's just so uh
so some pointed out the long hairstyles
look a lot like native american
hairstyles and wig wearing had to be
stopped or the nightmare was going to
this war was going to continue it's uh
yeah god's pissed
so cotton mather reminded his fellow
puritans that it was just an innocent
fashion
and questioned the threat of the wig
he's like guys it's actually just
something we like so and we calm down
it's probably not causing the war what
probably caused the wars we
killed some of their people foolish
cotton and then they killed some of ours
and then that started
foolish okay it was more about
good to absorb things really likes to
suck up
dumb [ __ ] cotton okay i'm just saying
okay loves to soak it up doesn't he
kill us we killed them that's why we're
a war
or maybe it's because you have hair
on your body that's not yours
idiot okay this is a good talk
this is what it's like it's a big covety
that's no that's exactly what it's like
about
when you're debating climate change on
twitter that was it oh
i'll tell you it's always fun though so
the reverend samuel stoddard preached in
favor of the
periwig he argued quote god allowed man
by art to supply the defects of nature i
mean
he's like look he gave us this ability
right but it's also stupid
god is pro-ish wig shut the [ __ ] up
god's up there like guys hey guys guys
guys seriously do so many other things
you're so off base you're so [ __ ]
awesome thank you for finally coming
down
maybe you can finally set some of these
fools straight about wearing
other people okay just hear me out no
let me finish
oh okay i guess you what in the [ __ ] are
you doing you're right go ahead why do
you give a [ __ ] about [ __ ] wings oh
lord you would not have put us on earth
i didn't wanted you to live in harmony
with these animals
the nature they're trying but some
people are wearing wigs
mucking it up for the rest of us that's
the next goal
the next thing we're gonna do after we
get rid of wigs is live in harmony with
nature and animals
but before we do you got a bunch of wig
wearing
[ __ ] i can't i can't believe please
did i have to watch this [ __ ] for 400
years until you get to micro dosing
i seriously cannot [ __ ] be oh lord
what a micro you is that hair related
lord
your words are so white i put mushrooms
all over the place
we would never eat anything no no
there's good ones god you wouldn't want
us to just nibble a little bit every day
you don't want us eating a little bit
every day
and calm the [ __ ] down but first first
lord please
set the sinners right about the wigs
i don't give a [ __ ] about the wigs lord
trust me
you even read the bible i wrote the god
i write
all my words i want to give it a read
lord
they got i don't know if you met a noise
on the ones and twos
but he reckons that that's how we're
going to get revelations out of the wig
he's a [ __ ] idiot no no listen lord
but you made him too
so so the locust will come from the hair
if women are too wet
and you made men a little dry no notes
we love everything else but men are too
dry for wigs
tell them tell them how you made men dry
so they can't wear wigs lord
i'll so far that don't meet your deities
is what i'm learning
this is a bit of a letdown
okay come back soon that went pretty
good
so some guys just said
the waves are there to keep their head
warm they're like no i just have it
because it's cold
and they were like but the lord made the
dog
but the woman didn't do in
november 1675 in response to wigs
causing the war
the general court passed laws
one authorized courts to proceed quote
either by
abd i can't [ __ ] this word it's not
i don't know i can't it's all jumbled so
fine or correction against the manifest
pride openly appearing amongst us
in that long hair like women's hair is
worn by some men
either their own or others hair made
into pay wigs so they're basically
saying the reason that we're
at war and we have to correct it is the
long hair awake thing and the court
and they passed a lot they passed a lot
oh good
good the court that's good and see see
why it's good to lead with religion when
it comes to law
that's right yeah in 1679 three men were
brought before the essex court for
wearing wigs and they were convicted and
admonished that might have been what the
word was
okay but when you're admonished are you
just is it i think
it's it's a scolding i think probably a
public shaming yeah i would imagine
you've been very bad you're a naughty
boy a bit
bad uh but the laws they still it didn't
put a dent in wig wearing
massachusetts is becoming more worldly
especially after it became a real
province in 1691 so wig wearing
is only continuing as the
colony becomes richer and more
cosmopolitan um
so samuel sewall and his uh anti-wig
buddies were always at war with wicks
what about life wouldn't it be fun
wouldn't a life be fun too
maybe meet someone and have a life i
mean think about you get a plot
yeah i'll settle down once i get fake
hair off of everyone
except women in november 1685 he scolded
a public notary for quote cutting off
his hair and wearing a parry wig of
contrary colors so he's just yelling it
right i mean what i know i can't they
had notaries then
i know i don't [ __ ] get it i mean i
guess it makes sense because you
a notary would be more important than
than it is now
i would think because it's just [ __ ]
i mean it just seems like forgery and
fakery there's nothing you can do yeah i
don't know what
i mean people probably i mean you just
said you were a doctor and you were a
doctor i mean surely being a notary
you're just like yeah i have a candle so
i'm a doctor i'm a notary now
not that everyone wanted to be out front
in the fight against
wigs even though they're against wigs
john higginson
a minister from salem gave sewell a
document he wrote called a treatise
against periwigs okay jesus
at first he told sewell to do whatever
he wanted with it but then sewell
was like i'm gonna print it and
distribute it and then higginson was
like
he said that quote he would not have
done it while he lived he's like nope
nope
not while i'm alive man because this wig
[ __ ] is hot
it is a hot topic so he writes this
thing and he it's kind of just for him
and this guy's like this is great yeah
it's a p it really
takes on wigs takes wigs to task sure
hands it to the
guy who's the biggest printer in the
colony and that guy's like i'm gonna
[ __ ] put this [ __ ] out there and then
he's like no
so he after i die he had a viral wig
letter yeah he but he was like it's too
powerful man and then people gonna come
at me and i'll be a wig guy
this guy really believed in his stuff
too he's like man look you can't print
this it's perfect
so um it's just so [ __ ]
it's cool it's totally cool
uh so that's because as much as one
group
hates wigs another group loves them and
wears them and defending them and
but i mean again it it's you know like
not it's not even like anti-religion
necessarily but
when you draw your weird line in the
sand it is going you're gonna
you're putting a big spotlight on
something and you're going to attract
people who don't believe in your
theology
that's just the way to get at you yeah
so it's like it's almost it's like
it's like say if someone were to change
your name and like give you a shitty
nickname
and then like that nickname caught on
you know the thing to do would be to
pretend like it didn't disturb you and
bother you when in reality it's just
you hate yeah it's your wig thing it
really doesn't matter that much but you
you hang on to it so [ __ ] tight and
it becomes your wake thing
and it's also one of those things that
once you've let someone know that it's a
problem for you
they can inflate it and use it to hurt
you because they're demonic
yeah that's also a problem i mean you
know you've given them power with a word
they've taken it it
like you are who you are a name is
actually irrelevant you i
i as a person i agree but there's this
level of respect
so you know all these other guys are
defending themselves they're saying wigs
keep us warm they look good
wigs keep us warm is the best it's it's
i mean it reminds me of
like i can't breathe with my mask on
yeah you know it
i'm on their side but it is it's kind of
it's a look come on
it's a little cheap when so when someone
after john hayward he said he wore his
wig because doctors had told them to so
it's a medical it's a medical wig you
know what i mean
come on i mean again you're forcing
people's hand yeah yes
now i mean it's weed it's like all right
fine yeah i medically need it is that
helpful can i go get high in my home now
you [ __ ]
andrew belcher took a jab at so by
saying his was for warmth and nothing
else was appropriate to wear to a
wedding
what i mean come on come on it's my
wedding week i have a wedding wig
so now we got medical wigs we got
occasional wedding wigs we got
warm wigs it's pretty good it is i mean
it's weedy
it's very weedy some thought the wedding
wig comment was an attack on sewell's
velvet
black cap which was considered now a
fashion faux pas
so his black black little skull cap
people think it looks stupid they're
like that's idiotic and he's like well
it keeps my head while they're walking
around and what are probably absurd wigs
yeah they're like you look like an idiot
he's like i literally please
please and he wore it everywhere for all
occasions it didn't matter and
and it embarrassed his friends like his
friends are like [ __ ] dude
but he's bald i know so but he's he's
bald but he's running around saying
this is how god made me well then take
off the [ __ ] skull cap right and they
all think the skull cap looks dumb
right i'm sure it did some said maybe
the puritans who hated wigs so much
should focus on things that were more
serious
name one name one
by the way we should never have said
that we should have always been like god
damn you guys found the perfect issue
then they would leave all the other
stuff alone yeah instead now they're
like
oh you don't like it when we're in
charge of your body huh
during a sermon cotton mothers said
quote one sign of a hypocrite was for a
man
to strain at a gnat and swallow a camel
to be zealous instead
against fashion taken up and used by the
best of men
and yet make no conscience of being
guilty
of great immoralities sorry i literally
stopped at swallow a camel
what does that mean what is that i think
he's saying
you're taking something small and making
it huge and like choking on it kind of
like
and we're all sucking a camel's dick
okay the sermon got weird today yeah
it's in revelations
uh sewell after reading that sermon
wrote in his diary quote
supposed he means the wearing of perry
wigs
so he's like it's tough to figure out
what he's talking about
he's just being sly in his little dark
privately snarky
i guess he means the wig i hope i
remember how to read sarcasm
um now i don't want you to think cotton
mather is a good guy because he wanted
puritans to focus less on wigs and more
on stuff like witchcraft magic and
devils right that's what i was sort of
saying right that's the thing
it's like these wig guys are [ __ ]
idiots but the other guys are like
but it's dumb it's like a dumb thing
whereas like which
that's where it gets really bad it's bad
and the i mean obviously like that's
like gets way worse but witchcraft is
also gender [ __ ]
and they're killing it and you die i
mean it's just they've got a lot more
fire water crazy in
that you know this is more like a uh
yeah it's it's
bull it's obviously [ __ ] but it's
like
you know you always would you always
would rather them chase the
thing that is the stupidest yeah that's
true so cotton had a big
role in the witchcraft case a so-called
witchcraft case against
goody glover who was convicted and then
executed convicted
and uh we sentenced you to a horrible
witch
the wig fit on her head she's a witch
yes
he also wrote a book that um some said
was responsible for the salem witch
trials right
so in 1692 sewell was one of the nine
judges at the salem witch trials
those were kind of like the voice judges
right they would spin their letters a
lot like the voice
right which yeah yeah if you think
there's a witch turn around
i'm sorry adam levine turned around
she's a witch i really like your spells
but
i am gonna have to say no i'm really
evil
i swear to god i just i just don't see
it look at the port
i you know the spells i'm not i don't
think the spells are there i could be
worse
maybe next year you said that last year
well i mean come back with something do
some magic you know i tried to but
the cat ran away like uh get a devil
partner you know do something
jesus it's just like i'm getting older
so yeah yeah i mean it's just not witchy
i don't feel like it's not i'm not
scared of you in any way okay
thank you so much for the note yeah next
year
oh exit this way or this way yeah yeah
the left okay or the woman said this way
okay go ahead which way is the waiting
room because my family's out there
cotton was not a judge at the salem
witch trials but he was president of the
executions
and he wrote a letter to the chief
justice congratulating him on the
executions
way to go we really did something good
today nice job with the kills
really good sewer sewell would later say
he regretted being a part of it
while cotton continued to defend the
witch trials for years and sounded like
he actually wanted to have more witch
trials sure he's like let's keep doing
this [ __ ]
so that's who they were right right um
so in june 1701 samuel uh
seawall it might be sea wall but uh was
informed that his own minister's son
josiah willard quote had cut off his
hair
a very full head of hair and put on a
wig oh my lord so
and that's particularly offensive
because imagine why are you replacing
what you just had with fake there's no
rationale that actually
imagine how [ __ ] angry he is he hears
those ministers
he's just he's just putting on his
[ __ ] buckle hat
and his his square buckle and his
black pants furious he's going to go
take care of some business
who walks down the street to his
minister's house
and the the wife answers and he
would like to see josiah give me josiah
move move woman
he then demands to know quote what
extremity had forced him to put off his
own hair
and put on a wig oh he goes right to the
guy the kid he goes to josiah right okay
and josiah is pretty straight to the
point he said well nothing forced me to
do it quote
he said his hair was straight and then
it parted behind so he's like
i don't like i don't like how it it i
mean we're not allowed to use product
it's pretty hard you guys have really
created a pretty hard situation to be
honest hair wise
it's god's way yeah but he gave me a
butt cut in the back it's kind of
bizarre
it's totally what's happening yeah yeah
you may not use product
and don't divert from the plan of
nothing
he said look the wig let me it lets me
have more fashionable elaborate look
so that's his reason right and this
guy's like he's like it's cosmetic and
this guy's like
and then he's kind of like yeah i'm not
really interested in this in this
he said it's a bigger conversation and
then he goes look
men might as well shave their hair off
their head as off their face he's like
why are you shaving off your face
not your head because uh
it's a great point it is it's a great
point yeah
or cut your nails seawall responded half
of mankind
never have beard so he's like where did
don't have b like he's just
he's got nothing he's just flailing
right that's a dumb [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and quote i told him that god seems to
have created our hair as a test
to see whether we can bring our minds to
be content at what he gives us
again i'd go back to the face it feels
like
until you answer that there's no more
arguing
so he's saying josiah has failed god's
test and put on a wig he's saying god
and why did you shave yesterday yeah i
mean it's a good it's
hard to come back from that yeah so
josiah was planning on becoming a
minister just like his dad
and so i told him to do that he had to
set an example and
teach men to deny these things
his wig would prove quote displeasing
and burdensome
to good men and he then reminded josiah
that he knew josiah knew whigs were bad
because josiah had been at a meeting
where whigs were condemned by the
ministers of northampton
so what he's saying he's ignored he knew
he's
he's now playing the employer card
so he's like oh oh you want to get in
the biz
right you remember all the [ __ ]
ministers that said wigs are bad and you
were in that room
and now you're going to wear a wig right
you want to get in this business
right you play it by the [ __ ] rules
right oh boy
the minister oh god it's just it's
it's just amazing how like if you
think you're his messenger the lord's
messenger oh god
it's just there's nothing you just get
to say all right everything's a crusade
everything yeah every you are allowed to
do everything and anything you want
yeah so josiah after that josiah backs
off
and then he indicates when his hair
grows back he'd stop wearing the wig
okay is sewell done no no a couple days
later he goes to talk to josiah's dad
about this crazy wig so he goes to his
minister the kid's dad about his crazy
wigs
the problem basically was so i mean what
better resolution could he have yeah
his dad i'd like him to grow his hair
back fully today his dad is super happy
by what transpired he thanked sewell for
waking his kid up about the dangers of
wigs
and said josiah's now says he's going to
grow his hair back out long enough to
cover his ears and then he would get rid
of the wig
great the minister also said he didn't
know and had he known he would have
forbidden josiah
from from buying the wig in the first
place but his mom had known
oh this guy he was going to buy the wig
no annoying nosy neighbor
but um bad news your wife uh
she did
he said uh quote but was afraid
positively to forbid him
lest he should do it and so be more
faulty so he's like
she if she told them and he went ahead
and bought it then he'd be like stuck in
it more and wouldn't want to
bail on it right kind of deal right sure
basically i have a lot of notes for the
family
this is apparently not enough which is
for sewell still
he had a hard time forgiving josiah for
wearing that buddy i mean
what do you want what do you want a few
months later josiah delivered a sermon
in his father's church and sewell
refused to attend
he went to another church for services
that day quote partly out of dislike
to mr josiah willard's cutting off his
hair
and wearing a wig okay really showed him
that was his dire entry like he's
writing this [ __ ] yeah so in his diary
right his diary is filled with anti-wig
[ __ ] biblical karen
he went on quote he that condemns the
law of nature is not fit to be a
publisher of the law of grace
in 1704 timothy clark
took up his wig when he met a group at
sewell's house as they prepared to walk
to visit the poor
and so he he said there's a bunch of
guys meeting at sewell's house and i
guess they're going to go help out the
poor
and then sewell sees the [ __ ] wig and
angry tells him
to think about a passage from isaiah
and the dude's like i what i don't know
totally shocked
like freaked out because this guy's like
a big guy in the town
to go help the homeless he's like before
you do that
think about how you're gonna go to hell
in 1708
ezekiel cheever died and sewell gave his
eulogy and ended it with quote
he abominated para weeks so he so he's
like
that's the last thing he said i think
his uh legacy will be that he
he really loathed wigs you really didn't
know that
he's just crazy he didn't like wigs and
i think
that's what he would want to be known
for but remember wigs are becoming more
and more popular no they're not
no they're not not really i've seen i've
actually think people are wearing them
less
to be honest the ones they're wearing
are bigger so maybe that's what it is no
they're
definitely become the more people are
wearing them a lot of people wearing
them
everybody's like so name the 500 people
who are wearing them right now
well 500 wow yeah it seems like you
don't have the numbers so
it feels like it's going down to me so i
guess i'm doing some good stuff
right not so happy now are you demi no
i'm just
because it's dwindling it's not it is
it's
not at all well but i think if you over
if you count there's less hair on the
wigs and i think that's
part of it what i've been doing that's
absolutely not true well what i'm saying
is that more
more people aren't wearing them than
less they did before
very much yeah they didn't look the [ __ ]
around you look the [ __ ] around
why don't you try looking around every
now and then are you too silly with all
your stuff
[ __ ] just don't be mad that the lord
hates you when he's listening to me
because he likes me better
okay okay i don't want to be here i
don't want to yeah
but i'm going to hear you how do you go
shave my goat
don't shave a goatee too he's not sure
put it in piles okay well i just want to
combine that you know things are
trending my way
so
uh well i would say attacked for not
wearing a wig in 1720 peter attacked
physically attacked but peter townsend
commented about from the money so
there's
it's like a town meeting and at this
time meaning peter townsend comments
about sewell's black cap by telling him
that he quote
should get a wig so in front of
everybody so now
he's got his little black cap on which
everyone hates and he's already been
mocked relentlessly for this stupid
black cap
yeah and so he's super just he's ashamed
in front of everybody for
wearing a black cat everyone's like he's
the old dude at the country club
he's now the old dude i was like man
respect the golf course
sewell said god gave him hair and he was
not going to start wearing
another hair but where's his he doesn't
have hair he doesn't have hair
but god gave him hair and then took it
away well now it's gone
yeah um i assume he said i didn't i he's
probably like i wasn't
faithful enough and now i lost my hair
but right he thinks it's wrong to get
some other hair
right his bald head
was his quote chief ornament is what he
said at the meeting
lord so he's embarrassed publicly right
days later
a widow that he was courting apparently
said she's not down with the black
cap no wig choice she's like i don't
like the black cat he's like
look if this happened three days ago
maybe
and yeah he's it quote was inconvenient
keeping out of a fashion commonly used
so she's saying you're stepping out of
this fashion trend
and it's not good and she's like come on
quit being a lame-o and he's like i'm
not i'm not i can't give
i can't get away you marry me and the
cap lady so she
she kicks into the curb because he won't
wear a wig
but i mean if he wore a wig and it would
have just been
like it's oh my god it's just he can't
wear a wig
he cannot wait you cannot wear it out
just just roll
and morning everybody i just uh
how are you what uh how's uh everyone's
ale
everyone having a good ale they're on
your head you are you enjoying your ales
i was thinking of having one myself and
then that's a wig oh this
oh oh am i me you talking you're the no
wig guy
is he saying yeah i'm me yes yes it's me
you hate wigs you have a wig on your
head
oh well i was um it's
actually really funny because um
i'm trying to think when i started
wearing it because it's been a while
today you were wearing yesterday
yesterday you had a black you had a
black skull cap on
i was wearing the black skull yesterday
it's funny because time is you've
never not worn the black you [ __ ]
yell at everybody for wearing wigs
yeah i mean i like animated
conversations that's not
is that is that a si if that's a sin
lord cast me down
um you call me an abomination what
you called me an abomination i am
curious about the ales but we'll get
into that in a second
i uh yes uh you were an obama and i'm an
obama
we're all obama no no no no no what i
don't understand
no i'm trying to find why you find this
inconsistent and it's a puzzling
you called my wife less than a goat
because she gave me her hair today
it's a turn of phrase moses it's not a
turn of phrase oh
that's a compliment in some counties i i
i i i wanted to duel you again this is
all about [ __ ] wigs
i mean i i i okay if we mut
and i'm hoping that everyone's having a
good ale because unfortunately i'm not
allowed to get an update on that yet
but um what i was going to say was that
um yeah it's one of the i mean i
feel like look ideally we're not wearing
wigs but like i've always sort of said
i'm a little loosey-goosey on parts of
it you know
um you can wear a wig from time to time
it's just no
you never said that i mean i i
definitely thought it i did
you said men shouldn't wear wigs because
god made us in a certain way and if we
put wigs on
then we were like ladies lady men you
would say
look look hey let's just
let's just do this let's just pretend
that our lives haven't happened until
today you're [ __ ] 62.
i look do i look 62 yeah i feel 31.
look at me right all it looks if
come on what are you talking about you
looked absolutely terrible i look great
i've never looked better
no you look it's like a hug
like a panther i've got a beautiful you
know i mean
i might wear the skull cap again i mean
who knows but for right now
i'm uh i'm loving this vibe i'm gonna
kill you tonight
what come on i wanna know how everyone's
ale is
and then they all cheer so what i look
like i'm from labyrinth
how's everyone doing so um
okay so he's like he's lost he's he's
he's widowed he's wigdoed
well it just goes on like that cotton
mather dies in 1728
samuel uh sewell died two years later
wig situation unresolved when they died
despite what a lot of people believe
george washington did not wear a wig
oh he didn't george washington was a
redhead and he
powdered his hair white because white
hair was
in and it was a sign of being wealthy
and smart and then his
whole goal was to just never move his
gums yeah
periwig weathering continued until the
final decades of the 18th century the
french revolution put a
serious dent in wigs being cool as they
became associated with the aristocracy
whose heads were being cut off
okay that is a good way too yeah so
we're hoping that happens with baldness
and bezos
yes so there were yeah so people again
they're like oh that's the bad people
right or or we just don't want to be
those people right so their wigs were
right the brits turned on wigs when a
hair tax was implemented
and they wanted to raise money so they
they created a hair tax in 1795
that's biden's proposing that
unless you had a reason like being a
member of the royal family or clergy or
whatever
i like to be a member of the royal
family's a reason i know one
had to buy a certificate to be able to
buy
hair powder and it cost the equivalent
of a hundred and twenty two dollars a
day
and people use the hair they use the
hair powder in the wigs right
so essentially so they're kind of
pricing out it really quickly just
killed
wigs and hair powder okay wig wearing
was gone in the early 1800s and
uh soon would come the rise of hats
and then don't worry gang we'll get
totally crazy on those too
crazy it's just
i mean you know it all these
little wedge issues are so stupid
and they're just totally i don't think
that that was
i don't think this was necessarily
rooted in that
necessarily that it's like a wedge issue
but it's a dumb hill to die
on yeah and it's really just like this
this thing of
interpreting god's will and stuff but
even when you think of today
we argue about the dumbest [ __ ] and it
does just keep happening and it's not
the most important [ __ ]
like it's as far as like people having
rights like everybody should have
rights i mean that is like pretty much a
no-brainer we need to actually
you know get people who understand that
and then we'll debate
issues that are bigger to our survival
in this planet yeah i mean but this is
this is the problem with this sort of
mentality you know
i'm sure there are worse things going on
at the time than wigs yeah
and obviously i'm not talking about
witches and stuff just survival and
right and how do we
how do we work with these native
americans
but it's the same thing now right you're
fighting over whether or not
some person can um because they have
chosen what they want to be
yeah uh you're you're screaming at them
because they want to run in a race when
in actuality
that's almost never happened you know
they say that i can't win a race because
a trans person beat me and there's like
no [ __ ] cases that it's not
it's like not a thing that happens well
they they just
they find a [ __ ] and the wig arguments
are the same [ __ ] thing they find a
[ __ ] thing and they scream about it
and you're like
hey climate change is happening and
you're [ __ ] screaming about that
well that's the lord's will yeah i mean
that is part of the art
but no i think that's a hundred percent
true and
but it is also when you can't win an
argument based on merit and facts you
invent a sky referee
and you just go he said it he said it he
said it he said it so we got to listen
to him
it's like you don't have your argument
is baseless useless
and also they go they always go back to
the bible which was written a hundred
years after
after jesus christ died so it's like
yeah
if it was written like no one knows what
actually the way the bible was
translated is the way that that
thing that gives you the text on your
stand-up clips works
like it's just it's [ __ ] up all over
and it just it would be like if someone
was using
those clip texts over and over again
to try it's just it's not it's no longer
a document that should be valued
it's really it's really crazy yeah and
we you know we hold on to these archaic
things but i mean let's go back to the
fact that
the puritans [ __ ] everything up from
the gekko yeah this would be
such a better country if puritans had
never
[ __ ] come here it's really terrible
well it's
a real shame it's a real shame with
rampant syphilis that the only group
that's not [ __ ] is them
it's like jesus if you really if i mean
it would be great if the puritans were
just you know [ __ ] like rabbits
yeah but instead no yeah
god gave you a hard [ __ ] and god gave
you a hole but those don't belong don't
do it
don't do it i always think about them
killing thomas morton and if thomas
morton had been able to create his own
state you know the guy who partied and
had yeah yeah
[ __ ] dancing and [ __ ] like if that
guy had been able to create his own
state
jesus yeah it'd be a whole different
country i mean we would all live in that
one part
the rest would just be nothing it would
just be wasteland with like
dusty churches that nobody went into no
i mean
yeah i i just i don't know i mean it i
like
faith and believing in the higher power
and all those things
it's like absolutely do it and you know
it just it never gives you a badge to
legislate what someone else
should or should not do i know
christians who don't
force any other [ __ ] on young people
they just live their life yes
yes the amer the american christian is a
very special
well we've baked into this version of
christianity
that it's your task to bring others with
you
yeah and that has [ __ ] it all up but
not only that but they've come they've
merged
capitalism and criticism
and religion used to stay out of power
like religion the whole thing was out of
politics and then like reagan like
amped it up and you know and then and
then once the once the church became a
voting group
and a way to like beat taxes and a way
to get leader jet like
you know it's just become dumber and
dumber yeah that's pretty bad
you know i mean and the fact that this
country is
you know anchored by that still it's
like dude i mean you know we we can't
i mean we should be so far beyond the
[ __ ] that we're debating
oh god it's just it's just crazy it's
just [ __ ] embarrassing
it is a joke and the fact that it it
holds such water with a group
and part of our country it's like you
know the most amazing thing
to me of all is is when people are like
trans people can't go in this bathroom
and you're like [ __ ] you sent
you send your [ __ ] family starting
out when your kids are
children into the [ __ ] catholic
church yeah i mean
you want to talk about the real [ __ ]
problem that happened there like
truly i mean you cannot live in a
dumpster and tell me to clean my house
yeah all the all those [ __ ] jim
bakers the [ __ ] rapist there's just
so much there's just
no it never ends so much [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that those people do
and it gets covered up and it's all and
yes because always
and then they scream at somebody else
and you're like [ __ ] off yeah
uh well we just attacked religion i'm
sure that'll be a thing yeah
without question god damn it yeah it's
all right
um no because it is not it's not saying
you don't support religion but if you
are a huge religious person you have to
understand
that other people in your religion are
pissing in the pool that you're swimming
in
oh yeah i mean we've talked to mormons
and and who have been like yeah i can't
oh yeah about [ __ ] yeah who love it
who love listening to mormon episodes
because they're like what the [ __ ]
yeah i mean yeah i know it's
i remember i mean i never went to church
as a kid and i remember the only time i
go to church is when i spent the night
at like other kids houses
and like i would go there on sunday
morning or whatever oh yeah yeah me too
and i'd always be like what are you
doing on
sunday you're like this is a load of
[ __ ] i remember once i went to um
my my uncle for the summer i stayed with
him and his wife summer uncle is a new
show you're doing for cbs right
yeah his wife was super religious
and and so they sent my parents didn't
know but they sent me to a summer
church camp like every day that's what i
did for like five hours and
i just remember sitting there and just
being like this [ __ ] is crazy
yeah yeah no you need you need you need
to not really have learned much before
you
learn about religion in order for it to
stick with you yeah even then i mean
yeah it's again you're allowed to
believe what you want just [ __ ] off and
leave us the rest
leave me alone
oh y'all can oh aaron now has
tissue stuffed up his nose so for those
of you worrying about the health of
us don't worry and by the way i'm never
gonna pray more than tonight
hoping that i don't get whatever
influenza aaron's brought in here it's
gonna be amazing if he gave us covet
dude if you can't if this is it imagine
listening back to this if we both die
from covenant
uh all right we signed gods
yeah thanks biz marquee died
what just sat down right
you